c'est le grand retour du duel droite
gauche pour ces élections
départementales dans les yvelines
si l'on pouvait croire que le second
tour se jouerait entre la liste de la
majorité sortante ensemble pour les
yvelines et le rassemblement national
il n'en fut rien la gauche dans son
ensemble n'a pas démérité là où il ya le
plus d'enjeux pour la gauche c'est le
canton de trappes seul canton où elle
est en tête
le binôme ali rabais anne-marie bouquet
divers gauche a obtenu 39 28 % des voix
non loin derrière anne capio nicolas
dainville pour eux p y
avec 36 points 97 % me réjouis de ce
score de premier tour la gauche et
l'écologie arrive en tête sur ce canton
de trappes elancourt la verrière nous
allons travailler d'arrache-pied pour
convaincre les abstentionnistes qui
n'ont pas voté au premier tour dans le
reste du département si la gauche n'est
pas en tête
elle n'en reste pas moins dans la course
et les scores sont parfois extrêmement
serré
dans le canton de montigny le bretonneux
composé de deux communes guyancourt et
montigny c'était aussi un duel de mer le
binôme divers gauche françois morton
maire de guyancourt et claire l'avenant
s'est positionné deuxième avec seulement
quatre points d'écart sur le rhum et
requêtes maire de montigny avec sa
binôme ou laurence boularan pour le pays
ibérique suis très heureuse d'arriver en
deuxième place avec un écart de voix qui
est relativement faible et donc on a su
proposer quelque chose on voit que ce
qu'on propose les valeurs qu'on propose
autres de l'écologie de la solidarité sa
part l'eau aux habitants et qui nous ont
rejoints sur ces thématiques là et en
arrivant en nous plaçant en deuxième
position
[Musique]
du côté de plaisir l'heure est à la
surprise l'écart est loin d'être immense
entrepôt y est le binôme divers gauche 7
points seulement
félicien margaritas et annie joël prix
ou ass ni obtiennent 33 0 5% des voix
contre 40 18% pour joséphine coleman ce
verger et bertrand coquard une
différence minime qui pourrait basculer
d'un côté ou de l'autre
avec le report des voix on est très
heureux du score que le conte a obtenu
hier donc dimanche d'argent aux
élections c'est un score qui raconte
quelque chose finalement
il dit que aujourd'hui avoir des élus
qui sont éloignés du terrain c'est pas
une fatalité et la gauche dans les
yvelines aujourd'hui est en capacité
d'année du renouvellement report des
voix qui pourraient surtout bénéficié
aux binômes divers gauche des mureaux
gwenaël riou et boris venons se place
pour le second tour avec 19 2% des voix
contre 30 3 84% pour eux p y
si 14 points les séparent un autre
binôme divers gauche est arrivée en
quatrième position
fatima kuni tour fils et michel mallet
avec 12 points 45% dans la logique le
report des voix bénéficierait donc à la
gauche dans son ensemble le pays grecque
pourrait donc perdre ce canton
le ballottage est aussi plutôt
favorables à gauche dans le canton de
rambouillet où le binôme représente en
europe ecologie les verts n'a qu'un peu
moins de dix points de retard sur le
binôme de la majorité sortante
david jutier et patricia milo pourrait
d'ailleurs bénéficier d'un report de
voix du binôme sans étiquette mais qui
avait axé sa campagne sur
l'environnement michael le saulnier et
nathalie stéphane on est on est tout à
fait satisfait évidemment des résultats
nous concernant pour ce premier tour qui
montre que sur le site d'yvelines il ya
une véritable envie d'écologie il ya une
envie de maîtriser notre urbanisme de
préserver notre environnement et c'est
clairement le résultat du travail qu'on
effectue depuis maintenant bientôt dix
ans pour les autres cantons la gauche
arrive généralement en deuxième position
sauf dans les cantons de bonnières sur
seine et de mantes la jolie mais les
écarts sont largement plus grand pour
les deux cantons où la gauche n'atteint
pas le second tour un seul bilan sans
une main pas de résultats
[Musique]